[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Karina an Android developer
advocate at Google
I'm Hadi and developer advocate at
JetBrains
and we're excited to announce a
collaboration between Google and
JetBrains
no matter if you're creating mobile
backend front-end desktop or even
embedded applications cotton is a
language that can deliver on all fronts
with so many possibilities developers
are hungry to learn more about Coughlin
and the opportunities it provides and
that is why we're launching a new series
of community led events named Kotlin
everywhere
that will take place all around the
world bringing developers together to
learn more about Kotlin and share their
experiences content-aware events are
offline meetups taking place between May
15th and November 30th featuring a
series of talks and workshops on how you
can use content on different platforms
and to connect you to folks in your
community that share this common
interest one it can involve sign up to
be an organizer by putting on an event
in your area full-day half-day or a
short meet-up all event types are
possible be a speaker at a local event
remember this is cotton everywhere so
whether you're doing mobile beckon or
you just love the coffee language any
topic is welcome so reach out to your
local community to speak so join the
party and come together to learn about
Kotlin everywhere
you
[Music]